don't cricketers The Shadow Cabinet
Office minister and he joins us now from
Westminster what's to be done well look
the first thing is we need to make sure
these public service contracts are
honored 50 prisons 200 operating
theaters in hospitals and all sorts of
other services now in some risk the
government must immediately guarantee
that those services will continue I'm
having reports already of work has been
laid off all over the country the
government must act I've been warning
them for some months and how this was
going to happen and then secondly we
need to review the way in which we hand
over really huge amounts of money
it's a profit-making companies and cream
off the profits and then just leave the
debts with the public sector and that is
an exceptional than third that we have
to have an explanation from the
government why they went into this open
eyed knowing the state of Karelian but
failed to stop the contrast flowing
across this is taxpayers money and it's
a disaster but they're not using
taxpayers money to bail them out and
they are confident that all of the
contracts that they went into like we've
just heard with Balfour Beatty that the
slack is going to be picked up by the
the other companies working alongside
well let's see what happens I'm very
worried about the supply chain you know
all those smart firms working in the
booty industry and elsewhere used by
Karelian can they stand the debts which
they're gonna not be paid now I think I
am worried about this and also about the
jobs but more importantly hundreds of
thousands of people depend on the public
services which Karelian was supposed to
be provided and the government knew the
company was in trouble as we've just
heard and yet failed to stop any further
contracts being handed over it's just an
it is a disaster I'm sorry to say though
the government says it did due diligence
what do you think went wrong when they
say they did do diligence what it means
is they looked at the company's accounts
they knew that the the the company was
in trouble and continued to hand over
contracts because they had other
objectives in mind honestly I think we
need a full inquiry into this but the
first thing is we need immediate action
and I think some of these services will
have to be bought Brackins of their
public service immediately because we
can't have hospitals
surgery's closing in the middle of this
NHS crisis the same with schools and
clearly we can't have prisons which are
not being managed so some of these
services will need to be immediately
brought back in-house it seems to me
yeah we've heard Sky News has done a bit
of research with the NHS this morning it
appears at the NHS not being as heavily
impacted as perhaps other public service
the majority of the contracts it seems
for hospitals are for cater and cleaning
Fortis and maintenance and then the NHS
sources a saying that trusts have
contingency plans in place so at least
mercifully it does appear that the
implications for the NHS might be
minimal well let me just put this to you
a hospital which is not being cleaned
let's say that's all that they're doing
in a hospital it's not a safe place to
be so we may say well cleaners are not
so important actually they are but I'm
told that they're also operating
theatres up and down the country six
hospitals be managed by Karelian okay I
think we need a full statement in the
house this afternoon from the government
I was asking questions last Wednesday I
didn't get satisfactory answers and we
must have them today do you think that
the government should now spend
taxpayers money on sorting this out or
do you think that they're right just to
stand back and say this is karelians
problem Korea needs to do it well look
the government itself has made these
disastrous decisions to continue handing
contracts over taxpayers money to affirm
they knew what was going boss I'm not
surprised that they're saying that and
let's see where we finish up but I'm not
in favor of any further money going into
Karelian itself which has been
deplorable in managed by the way they've
had three separate chief executives
recently and as long as goes to out 2015
the shares will being sold off look this
has been a long time coming and it's
time that the government immediately
acted today to save the services and
protect the jobs and Pensions what about
retention
do you think that that should happen in
some of these locations I think the
easiest well looks quite a lot of this
work is in the private sector how that
sandal is up to the liquidators and I
hope that's done quickly because so many
people depend on chronium for work and
for services but for public services the
easiest ways to simply say we'll bring
them back in-house
I mean prisons ought to be run by the
public service not for
profit it just seems to me so basic but
that is the case that he not not so been
done in the first place so we're looking
for these services to come back in-house
into the public service straight away
what about pensions the pensions
regulator is telling Karelian pension
holders not to be alarmed are you
confident that they they won't then lose
out I'm not confident yet I think we
need to know more about the pensions
it's almost a billion pounds and there
again if the government is saying
there's no tax payers money going in how
are they going to protect the pensions
of the workforce and clearly all of this
need not have happened had the
government acted speedily and in time
many months ago when this problem first
emerged ok don't wreck it good story
thanks very much